[Music]
Thor embedding Stormbreaker into
Thanos's chest had many fans going
[Music]
however it still left one large
lingering question at the end of
infinity war how did they not survive
this normally fatal attack after waiting
months we finally have an answer to the
question spotted by reddit user evil
cartoonist the Eagle Eye Buick note is
that right before thanasis capes by
using the space stone you can see the
subtle sparkle of the tiny stone this
clears up one of the huge gaping plot
holes in infinity war and is something
that I never even noticed when watching
it originally I thought his death may
have been reversed by the soul stone
which has the power over life and death
however the time stone is definitely
adequate at healing as we saw in the
film Doctor Strange when the titular
character was experimenting on an apple
that is able to bring things back from
the brink it's another nice little
detail infinity war that once again
elevates it above most other comic book
films and I'm glad that we finally have
an answer to this burning question so
did you spot the time stone shining in
infinity war is there anything else
you've noticed that others have missed
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film recently I
discussed the fan theory that Odin was
in fact the original person who sought
out the Infinity stones so make sure you
check out that video next linked at the
end of this one thanks very much for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]
you